all too often with every crisis comes
opportunities for crooks and that's
certainly the case during this pandemic
Americans are being cheated out of
millions of dollars as I learned when I
talked earlier with the Connecticut
Attorney General William Tom mr.
Attorney General thank you so much for
joining us these scammers they can't
help themselves it seems even during a
pandemic no they can't if this gives
them real opportunity as you know
scamming has become big business it's
cheap it's easy they can do it from
places not in Connecticut not in the
United States and many of us are at risk
and what can you do about it if they're
overseas so the biggest thing we can do
is work with our federal partners to
stop them when they try to scam us but
also really just to educate people over
and over again to hammer home the
message that if you get a phone call you
get a text message you get an email
offering you something that's too good
to be true
offering you something you've from
someone you've never heard from before
be careful be careful know what you know
which is that nobody's gonna call you on
the phone and ask you for your social
security number or your credit card
information they're definitely not gonna
call you and ask you to send them gift
cards and and just be careful we have a
couple of the phone calls that's been
recorded by you and by the federal
authorities let's listen to a couple of
them starting with this one which where
they say your Social Security benefits
have been suspended this is a call from
the Social Security Administration
during these difficult times of the
coronavirus we regret to inform you that
we have got in order to suspend your
socials immediately within 24 hours due
to suspicious and fraudulent activities
found on your socials we are contacting
you as this case is critical and needs
your urgent attention yeah I mean people
right now given that many people have
either lost their jobs or working
reduced hours or their small businesses
are at risk or shut down permanently or
temporarily people are really feel
insecure in terms of their wallets and
pocketbooks and and financially people
are at risk and so any kind of scam that
focuses on taking advantage of you when
you're afraid of what the financial
future is for you and your family those
are particularly dangerous right now and
we'll the Social Security Administration
call you and say your benefits have been
suspended no no they won't the IRS isn't
going to call you and tell you that
unless you pay right now several
thousand dollars you're gonna go to jail
none of that is going to happen and
Brian I think people know that but but
the trouble is when you get a phone call
and you pick up a landline or even your
cell phone you get an email and it looks
legit it sounds legit or if they just
catch you at a weak moment that's that's
why it's scary good smart capable people
get scammed all the time here's one
where they say we've got free delivery
to you of Center cisors and all sorts of
things you need at your home do your
customer do too corona virus outbreak we
deliver a wide range of sanitizers hand
wash toilet papers and face masks at
your doorstep to safeguard you and your
family from coronavirus no need to visit
stores get delivery in 24 hours to order
press 1 for more knowledge and safety
tips about coronavirus press 2 at the
end they say press 1 if you want it
press 2 if you don't what's the scam
press 1 and press 2 is their gateway to
get you on the phone with a live person
and that's that opens the door to any
kind of fast talk about hand sanitizer
masks cures access to quick testing and
then as you may have heard there's a
variety of different scams related to
stimulus checks so by pressing 1 or 2 on
any of these calls that generally put
you in touch with a live person and it
also confirms with a skimmer there's
somebody there there's a mark there and
we should work on them and here's one
where they say do you want a free
testing kit response act has made
coronavirus testing more accessible
immediately if you want to receive a
free testing kit delivered overnight to
your home
press one if you do not want your free
testing prosecute so and again they say
press one if you want it press two if
you don't there's no free testing kit is
there's there's no free testing kit
there's no cure there's no vaccine yet
there's no get get you know a test
expedited there's none of that the best
way to get tested is through your doctor
through your local hospital hospital or
public health officials don't trust any
offers to test you quickly give you a
different kind of test that's more
effective give you access to cures that
nobody else has access to again people
note this and and and they understand
they're scammers out there the trouble
is you catch someone when when they're
not a great place and they're worried
about their family members if someone's
gotten sick or they're desperate for
information or help that's when they get
taken advantage of how are these
scammers getting the phone numbers they
use to call and make the pitch Oh
variety of ways
many of them are cold calling many of
them canvassed publicly available
information and data and many of them
have access to big data so all of us
know that when we log into our computers
now that big data enables major
retailers and organizations advocacy
organizations to reach out to us they
know we're searching for example if you
look I like the fish so if you look at
if you're a field and stream subscriber
for example somebody knows that you like
to fish them so they'll send you a bunch
of a bunch of offers around fishing you
know if you're into current events or
I'm a Democrat you know and I I read
articles and sign up for websites or
organizations that tend to be aligned
with my point of view and my political
affiliation big data enables other
people to access that information and
target you so
then access to that kind of data data
they can target you they might know that
you for example if you're over 65 and
you have four grandchildren they might
be able to figure that out if they see
that you're a mom and you're always
looking online for information related
to health care and children's health
care they can target you on that basis
here's a call that targets people with
student loan debt saying that we'll take
care of the waving of the student loan
payments important message regarding the
effects of the credit virus outbreak on
your student loans as you may have
already heard a president Trump invoked
his power as commander-in-chief by
declaring a national emergency due to
the widespread impacts of private 19 new
measures will include waiving interest
on your federal student loans until
further notice for more information on
how these new measures will impact your
future payment obligations call us back
today are you gonna get a cold call like
that from the government about getting
rid of your student loan payments no
you're not gonna get a cold call about
waiving your student loan payments again
that's a the too good to be true
category right and the government
doesn't have the resources to call each
and every person to offer to give them
money back so again I say that only to
emphasize that we know these things and
we just need to as I say to people and
Connecticut know what you know and if
you get a phone call or an email or text
message take a deep breath another scam
we haven't talked about our charities
people are really concerned about people
in their community and charitable
contributions and they want to give they
want to be helpful in this day and age
but if someone calls you and asks you
for money on the phone don't give it out
right away take a deep breath check with
your local Consumer Protection
Department or your attorney general's to
office and make sure that they're a
legit charity and you should give money
to them in addition to the scans that
come in by phone you're also
investigating other bigger frauds and
bigger crimes right sure so we have a
lot of work trying to protect people on
online platforms you have major scammer
activity going on on the major online
marketplaces like Amazon and eBay and
other
places we're looking at the way people
are treated by major travel companies
hotels airlines cruise ship companies
and making sure that if people have a
right to cancel their trips or get some
kind of relief or refund that they have
access to that and they're not being
abused of course the work of my office
focused on even bigger scams and frauds
like the generic drug price-fixing case
that I'm leading on behalf of 51 states
and territories that work continues as
well so there's a lot of money to be
made by the scammers and it's not just
we fix sometimes just the elderly who
fall victim to this is it no it it
happens to everybody it happened to my
mom I'm starting to say you know she's a
pretty savvy
she's a pretty savvy immigrant
businesswoman you wouldn't want to mess
with my mom but you know they caught her
on a bad day and she was swindled out of
several thousand dollars related to the
renting of an apartment that she rents
to people so everybody is at risk
everybody can be a target and again we
need to be careful and know that nobody
is gonna call you who's legitimate and
ask you for money in a spot credit card
number
no one's gonna call you and ask you to
send them gift cards and no one's gonna
offer you something that is is is not
generally and widely available to
everybody else so again some some you
know get tested faster scheme or
get-rich-quick scheme or get your
stimulus check quicker any of those
scams are recognizable because it's just
not believable that you would have
access to this and nobody else would and
you would get it through a random phone
call and is there a place somewhere that
our viewers can go online to see if
they're being dealt with by scammers
sure you can always go wherever you're
listening from you can are watching from
you can go to your local Department of
Consumer Protection usually that's a
state agency or the office of your
Attorney General in Connecticut this
should go to our department of consumer
protection website or to my website CT
govt /ag it's the same in other states
and we're here to help
Attorney General William Tong thank you
so much for your time and for your
advice
Thank You Bryan really appreciate it